Now Sunshine is dependent on the open
weather map service for its weather
data, and we don't have control over
how we communicate with their servers.
And I already said that I wasn't going
to teach you about servers today.
But I will teach you about GCM,
and to do that,
I'm going to fake a few
severe weather alerts.
In the United States, the National
Weather Service issues severe weather
alerts when a hurricane, tornado,
tropical storm, blizzard or
a similarly severe weather
pattern is likely in an area.
This weather does not happen
daily in most places.
I'm looking at you, tornado alley.
But when it does happen, it's vital
that your users be aware of the danger.
And that means that these would
be time-sensitive alerts and
not nice-to-know facts tomorrow morning.
So let's dive in.
So normally we would have a shiny server
that subscribes to weather alerts.
So then when a new alert happens,
the server will see it first.
Then it can take that alert and
use it to make a push notification.
And then it can send that
notification to each affected device.
In this case, devices that are in the
region that we're concerned about for
the weather alert.
But, of course,
before we begin you need to take
a trip to the Google API console.